[Music]  kicking off et's kardashian ketchup Kim  and sang quest the 36 year old mama and  14 month old Saint adorably played with  snapchat filters and rocked matching  Easy's while waiting to watch sister  Kendall Jenner walk in the Versace  Fashion Show full dream come true the 21  year old model looked futuristic chic on  the runway during Milan Fashion Week in  Italy I just go with how I feel  meanwhile khloe kardashian is feeling  the love over in jamaica with her NBA  pro beau Tristan Thompson the 32 year  old reality star took to Instagram to  share this sweet snap cozied up next to  her buff man in the ocean captioning the  pic my love  [Music]  you